[Musica]
un saluto a tutti
sono un musicista
sono un musico terapista
è solo un istruttore di moto e sono
tutte queste cose insieme
l'idea che cercherò di
spiegarvi quest'oggi il mio metodo si
chiama suleiman swing è nato diversi
anni fa
prima del nome prima del logo è nato
quando io facevo l'atleta quando
gareggiavo per lottieri moto tanti anni
fa anche se adesso non si vede ma prima
era un atleta
mi divertivo a suonare tutto quello che
è nuotavo e mi divertivo osservare tutti
gli altri atleti nelle gare
a osservare ad ascoltare quei suoni che
in realtà non si sentono ovvero
questioni che stanno sott'acqua
e curava tutti i particolari
ritmici degli schemi motori degli
afflitti vi abbiamo iniziato ho
costruito sempre musiche aderenti ai
vari stili quindi al delfino quindi alla
rana quindi al dorso e allo stile libero
e ho pensato che in fondo musicisti e
nuotatori sono sono fratelli e non lo
sanno se voi pensate a un batterista che
fa quattro cose diverse e
contemporaneamente e pensate a uno stile
liberista che fa quattro cose diverse
contemporaneamente anzi 5 perché respira
quindi l'indipendenza dei quattro arti e
mi incuriosiva musicare
il gesto
il gesto atletico
e poi negli anni ho costruito una
didattica o apertò dei corsi e ho
iniziato in un imbarazzo
incredibile voi immaginate che io quando
ho capito che questo approccio poteva
avere poteva essere divertente sì ma
prima di tutto poteva essere
concreto ed efficace ho dovuto
attraversare gli spogliatoi di una
piscina
con una cassa in testa una casa di
batteria in testa un basso a tracolla un
amplificatore per basso è
tra le risate della gente immagina uno
spogliatoio di una piscina
tutti che ridevano mentre io portavo gli
strumenti a bordo vasca
perché in effetti quando è un'idea e la
vuoi concretizzare
e difficile attraversare il primo
momento l'imbarazzo laddove non ti senti
sicuro là dove non sai ancora cosa potrà
accadere
prima ho iniziato con me come stesso
suonavo col basso con le percussioni dei
ritmi quindi trovo in acqua notavo
scivoli suonavo mi asciugavo è di nuovo
in acqua poi di nuovo fuori dall'acqua e
via che provavo esercizi del mio
insegnante massimo moriconi bassista di
meno a grande musicista
e ho iniziato a provare la didattica la
didattica musicale di questo luminare
dal basso suini arti e poi sugli arti
dei miei allievi
ed è interessante che questo progetto
iniziato con ragazzi con disabilità
quindi ho iniziato a musicare movimenti
che avevano difficoltà a esprimersi
se penso a luigi
medaglia di bronzo ai campionati
italiani paralimpici
dopo un incidente stradale ha imparato a
nuotare con una
somma
marcata disabilità lui è in carrozzina
non nuova il braccio sinistro e solo col
braccio destro ha imparato a nuotare sui
brani di sting piero marras
è l'aver fortitu tre generi
completamente diversi
lontanissimi ma ha provato a immaginare
dei suoni con gli arti mancanti con gli
arti non funzionanti e via via è saltata
forma didattica interessante
interessante a tal punto che io che
insegnava 18 con la musica e con la
musicoterapia
e facevo elezioni a persone con
disabilità mi son ritrovato
aviv per l'inclusione al contrario
quindi persone senza disabilità che
bussavano la nostra piscina per far i
corsi e quindi si è creato un gruppo di
inclusione un progetto dove persone
disabili e persone non disabili lavorano
insieme suonano insieme perché la musica
non si sceglie le persone
la musica non si sceglie
la persona che cammina bene o la persona
che cammina in carrozzina la musica per
tutti è il vero strumento di
integrazione
l'arte come l'acqua se ci pensate acqua
e musica voi non potete fermarle
non ne potete acchiappare afferrare sia
sia la musica che l'acqua e quindi
questo progetto è andato avanti è andato
avanti l'idea è stata finanziata dalla
regione sardegna è via via cresciuta
sempre di più e nella mia follia pensavo
ai sogni sa cosa mi sarebbe piaciuto
fare e mi ricordo il giorno che ha detto
questa frase quindi il primo dei due
sogni
mi piacerebbe suonare su un campione di
nuoto su un campione mondiale di nuoto
perché già allora musica va i video dei
grandi campioni
e con tutti i loro movimenti e dicevo mi
piacerebbe musicare un grande campione
di nuoto
e mi piacerebbe suonarci sopra con la
mia band con dei musicisti magari di
alto livello e mi ricordo che fui
l'unico non ridere quando quando quando
ho detto questa cosa perché in effetti
poi
questo sogno si è appoggiato su tante
risate a comprensibili e quindi anche lì
l'imbarazzo
niente sognavo questa cosa perché alla
fine sono tutti anche pessimisti sognano
figuriamoci un ingenuo come e quindi via
via che il tempo passava ho iniziato a
crederci a crederci è l'anno scorso
siamo gennaio esattamente l'anno scorso
nell'evento di inclusione della chiusura
del progetto della regione sardegna
ho musicato la nuotata di filippo
magnini campione del mondo di 100 stile
libero due volte campione del mondo dei
100 stile libero prima ho collaborato
con il suo biomeccanico ho suonato tutti
i suoi movimenti
ho costruito una canzone ho suonato
sopra in star in sala di registrazione
con una band
e poi e poi
la cosa più assurda
abbiamo suonato live su filippo magnini
lui è venuto è sbarcato ad alghero è
arrivato a sassari è entrato in piscina
io e lui non ci conoscevamo è stato è
stato un momento
per me bellissimo ma terrificante perché
in questa cosa ci credo solo io io
ovviamente il mio team mio team composto
da psicomotricista e funzionali
neuropsicomotricista e poi da oggi se
clinica musicisti pianisti batteristi
allenatori quindi stiamo parlando di
nutella acciughe di cos'è che
apparentemente non c'entrano niente
l'una con l'altra
ebbene è arrivato filippo magnini alla
mia destra aveva massimo moriconi
bassista di mina
la mia sinistra vuol chitarrista di
sanremo 2021 max rosati chitarrista di
fiorella mannoia più la mia band era sui
mensili brand e abbiamo suonato live su
filippo magnini che aveva fatto un cenno
io ero sicuro che avremmo suonato ciò
che accade sopra ciò che ritmicamente
udibile e ciò che accade sotto che non
si sente quindi quindi vi dovete fidare
di me
perché se una nottata e corretta sotto
io riesco a suonarla e sia un gesto si
può fare si può musicare si può
tracciare vuol dire che ho la garanzia
che quel gesto è lì non più o meno lì
perché non musica e matematica è
emozione ma anche a matematica e quindi
abbiamo suonato live su filippo magnini
un po spaventati perché non stiamo
parlando degli atleti che segue york
sassari fortissimi tra l'altro ragazzini
di 12 anni che sfrecciano ma stiamo
parlando di uno dei più veloci di sempre
quindi anche alle nostre dita hanno un
po bruciato ecco quindi è stato
interessante a suonare suonare su questo
motoscafo che ha quindi effetti però era
regolare il suo time in gara perfetto
355 di metronomo insetti o cavi e niente
il campione di tal mondo di nuoto il due
volte campione del mondo di nuoto shane
contratto
nello stesso punto col miglior bassista
italiano
che non sono io ma il mio maestro
ovviamente e quindi è stato per me un
sospiro di sollievo vedere che dopo che
lui ha fatto il 50 forte noi eravamo lì
lì perché era tutto calcolato quindi
questo è stato veramente veramente
un punto importante nella mia vita e per
tutto il mio team manderei perché se non
faccio vedere il video ovviamente
vogliono andate lo psichiatra perché in
effetti solo a pronunciarlo a questa
cosa e folle per mandare il video di
filippo magnini musicato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la bellissima voce che avete sentito e
bianca fra o che ha cantato il pezzo
scritto da giulia salis con la swing
band
questo lavoro si che ovviamente molto
veloce l'atleta per cui magari è
difficile capire particolari però è
stato costruito su dei grafici
biomeccanici di unghie del suo
biomeccanico quindi abbiamo musicato
istanti musicali quindi la struttura
proprio
della nuotata è stata costruita su delle
certezze su dei movimenti musicati con
una durata corrispondente ai suoi gesti
poi ovviamente il pezzo anche carino e
divertente e quindi io una volta che è
la base ci lavori sopra e ti diverti
perché ci sono notate molto interessanti
come quella di federica pellegrini come
quella di popov michael phelps sto
citando atleti la stessa benedetta
pilato
ecco questo è stato il lavoro
razionale su una cosa che è stata
casualmente divertente insomma ecco
ora
vorrei invece in parlarvi di luigi
vorrei prima suonarlo luigi il ragazzo
di cui vi parlavo
un ragazzo che ha dovuto affrontare
insomma la sua disabilità
con la musica e con il nuoto
[Musica]
manderà il secondo pezzo il video di
luigi
[Musica]
tra la lenta un pelino alla fine perché
deve appoggiarsi almeno un braccio lui
ha bisogno di rallentare per il resto è
stato bello a suonare su un
nuotatore perfetto da potete vista
ritmico perché questo brano è stato
registrato
sulla sua nuotata e lui non sentiva la
musica lui ha ricordato perché poi fanno
questi esercizi tutti gli atleti insieme
persone del settore paralimpico e
persone è un anno disabilità insieme
fanno le jam session e poi entrano in
acqua nuotare ciò che suonano
perché questo è prima di tutto un
progetto di inclusione
là dove
tutti si incontrano
grazie all'acqua e all'arte adesso vi
faccio sentire alcuni
alcuni pezzi
un esempio di esercizio per esempio
immagino la battuta di gambe di alcuni
atleti che mi vengono in mente
e gli esercizi che allora devono fare
con i piedi quei piedi è con
le mani quindi con le braccia
insieme
per migliorare la loro precisione ora io
costo suonando sono ben piantato per
terra quindi
se suono su un metronomo su una canzone
sono sicuro di stare sul tempo un po
l'esperienza un po la sicurezza della
solidità del pavimento mi aiutano a
stare sul tempo immaginiamo invece chi
nuota chi ha sospeso cioè chi si
appoggia a un sostegno a cedevole come
l'acqua li devi avere un massimo
controllo e quindi i ragazzi si sfidano
anche un po sembrando anche un po non
piacendo si no perché tu fai dei ritmi
difficili in acqua rischi anche se sei
bello da vedere di di essere goffo
quindi sfido la loro estetica
natatoria proponendogli degli esercizi
che migliorano la loro precisione quindi
[Musica]
ora quassù loro pensano
chiamiamo nell a dei pattern musicali
che io suono e loro devono ricalcare lì
con i piedi sopra questo pezzo che
accade che però faccio delle frustate
con le mani che
sottolineano l'incastro che c'è tra arti
inferiori e superiori ovviamente a
determinate velocità
[Musica]
immaginiamo che la loro performance sia
più incalzante
[Musica]
quindi è divertente ma allo stesso tempo
stesso tempo
ecco se dovessi conoscere
più a fondo che ne so
magnini anche nella collaborazione che
stiamo aprendo con lui e con claudio
rossetto allenatore della nazionale mi
piacerebbe sfila sfidarlo qua
[Musica]
ovvero
chiedere
all'atleta evoluto di sviluppare questo
tipo di esercizio prima a velocità
piuttosto contenute e poi via via
rimbalzare sul tempo
ovvero adesso io riesco andare così
veloce perché è l'intenzione ritmica
questo respiro che do mi appoggio cioè
non faccio questo
[Musica]
ritmo abbastanza no granitico in acqua
non devi essere granitico non quanti di
di appoggiare td di rilassare per cui
devi respirare questo tipo di approccio
[Musica]
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]